to just Goosebumps everywhere Apple
chills
what a freaking episode what is going on
there citizens of the reject Nation we
are here to watch the final episode for
season one of The Last of Us joined of
course but my handsome friend here at
Andrew the Gordon acre 7-Eleven how are
you buddy I am doing good quick question
do you think Abby's gonna be in this
episode no I do not think Abby I do
think so we're going to see at the end
who the intelligent one is and who the
dumb one is okay get ready to feel like
a sour bust guys please go ahead leave a
like it means the world to me for
everyone who's been watching with us for
these entire nine weeks I'm just hoping
that one day I could have as great a
facial hair as Pedro Pascal does in this
show because today I have a public
service announcement from today's video
sponsor which is manscaped the leaders
in the now below the waist grooming now
have beard products and they've also
enhanced their brand new weed whacker
2.0 so guys and Andrew get ready to use
our code Rejects and at manscape.com and
get 20 off plus free shipping let me
tell you why I already use their
products religiously I'm a married man
if I've got a nasty situation downstairs
and your nose my brutally honest wife
she's gonna let me know so while I got a
lot of products for the balls which just
make for a very confident situation not
showing all those images makes it look
like I got a medical condition I just
take care of myself as should you I
should you but now they have the beard
hedger Pro kit when I opened the package
this morning I got so excited threw it
on my wife's head woke her up in the
morning I said look what I got so they
got this cordless electric beard hedger
here's just one reason why I love it let
me let me get my old let me get my old
beard trimmer here it is I've had to
resort to putting the links in a baggie
because it's just a constant mess which
one is it I can't find is this the right
Andrew can you get that trash over there
score that put
I put Andrew so this beard hedger Pro
comes in this Nifty little case and you
might be wondering like Hey where's all
the links only got one like no they're
all right here adjustable tough on the
hair but smooth on the face they say
let's find out baby
yeah yeah get those cheeks Andrew I
gotta do a full beard trim later but
thank you Andrew you cleaned up you
cleaned up good boy they also got the
latest weed whacker 2.0 they got
improved blades and no tugging guarantee
so I got a deviated septum so I got this
one spot that's really hard to get
Andrew clean that up Andrew yeah yeah
doing man the beard trimmer Pro crate
also comes with a beer shampoo and
conditioner beard oil and beard bomb to
moisture style and Shimmer your new
beard the kit also has three free gifts
beard brush comb and scissors baby and
for the classic manscape Thrills they
now have the performance package 4.0
which does include the weed whacker 2.0
and all the other lower region products
there's a few Brands I've worked with
where I have personally remained a loyal
customer and manscaped is definitely one
of them my wife wouldn't have married me
if it wasn't for manscaped manscapes
saved my marriage so guys but especially
Andrew you should get it to get 20 off
plus free shipping go to manscape.com
use our promo code Rejects at checkout
once again that's manscape.com use our
promo code rejects 20 off plus free
shipping use R code hours I want them to
know we've created other manscape salads
because they're the right tools for the
job
[Music]
oh
oh Ashley Jones is that her yeah it is
her you're right she's pregnant with
Ellie
sounds just like love it
[Music]
oh my God it kind of looks like you know
what I'm thinking right Farmhouse yeah
I know which one you're talking about
yeah
oh my God it's so good hearing her voice
I know she's got such an amazing voice
God
[Music]
oh my God nice
fantastic
because they let Ashley Johnson use the
knife he's just thinking that oh [__] is
that Ellie's knife
yeah yeah yeah Ellie's born
oh
oh she was dead in her first thought was
just spending time with her yeah Born To
Survive
[Music]
that's an opening right there yeah
that's amazing Ah that's so good to see
her oh it kind of reminded me a little
bit of Blade as well pregnant with
Bladen attacked by a vampire
whoa
oh my God it's not your fault we would
delay getting out of his own I she's
hungry
I didn't want to nurse her
find someone to bring her up and make
sure that she's safe
and I want you to give her this
was her knife yeah
only
how long have we known each other
[Music]
wow so you pick her up right now
and then you kill me
oh my goodness
oh he's turning
well history with Marlene dates way back
I can't kill you
please
I'll have someone else do it
[Music]
cover her ears
oh
we're in that first episode she was like
are you like my mother or something she
was like a surrogate mother well I found
this in there
Beefaroni Chef Boyardee
he had a guitar in that RV
oh in fact I was thinking maybe I could
teach you
want to learn how to play guitar
Ellie
oh yeah poorly that'd be great
I love how he's evolved into being more
outspoken and she's become a lot more
sheltered and closed off this is what
I'm thinking cut through that building
to get around that stuff find a scratch
paper gloves
this time I was thinking we blessed our
way through that Rubble I found some
dynamite in that RV back there really
no so we're gonna cut through that
building
where had you going didn't I
so good together
if I get you up there you can drop that
ladder down maybe we go through that way
game stuff okay
you kind of seem extra quiet today so oh
I'm sorry oh
damn you David damn you come on
yes yes
right when she looked I knew it I wonder
if they got a real one
there it is
they had this music with Bill and Frank
too
semblance of peace
it's all right
can you hurry up come on
[Music]
it says Pennsylvania Clark Field too in
the back
this evening
[Music]
so [__] cool
well where's she going
so
[Music]
is it everything you hoped for
deception down
we don't have to do this
just go back to Tommy's we forget about
the whole damn thing
I've been through
and when we're done we'll go wherever
you want Tommy's
[Music]
cheap ranch
the Moon
follow you anywhere you go
oh but there's no halfway with this
we finished what we started making
Jackson what it is now makes the choice
even more tempting to just turn around
absolutely yeah
[Music]
thank you
Emmy nominations
right
damn they did it no
emergency medical camps man me and one
just like this with Sarah oh here we go
let's release the guy who shot and
missed well I gotta hand it to the army
people they were way better at stitching
you up than I was it was me I was the
guy who shot and missed
I couldn't see the point anymore and I
wasn't scared either I was ready
I went to pull the trigger I flinched
anyway the reason I'm telling you all
this you know why you're telling me all
this
yeah I reckon you do
so Time Heals all wounds I guess
[Music]
it wasn't Titanic
ha ha ha
I'm glad that
that didn't work out
me too
[Music]
you probably get going yeah
walk it off walk it off guys I thought
they were gonna do the picture moment
but that made up for it that whole story
was amazing it makes sense that Joel
would want to at least Adept it you know
what I'm in the mood for shitty puns
moon rocks tastes better than Earth
rocks why because they're meteors it's
terrible that was actually good that's a
zero out of ten what did the green grape
say to the purple grape really if you
would eat it
does a three out of ten whoa oh whoa
whoa
[Music]
this man and little girl are clearly a
threat
's only job was to protect me I still
almost got killed how'd you do it
is over
just take me to her
I can't
she's being prepped for surgery
it makes normal cordyceps think the
cheese cordyceps it's why she's immune
he's going to remove it from her produce
those chemical Messengers
and then we can give it to everyone
he thinks it could be a cure Joel
oh boy cordyceps grows inside the brain
it does
we didn't tell her we didn't cause her
any fear there won't be any pain no you
take me to her you take me to her right
now
please you don't understand
they do
damn I was there when she was born
yeah I promised so I do understand
[__] I have no other choice
I do
he tries anything
shoot him
man their behave so cold this Hospital
looks exactly the same
I didn't hear anyone say stop
which way
downstairs
the [__] are you doing keep walking
instead keep walking
oh
where is she
I don't have time for this oh
[Music]
I got goosebumps into heaven
nicely done
[Music]
is in Terminator mode right now
I love this music yeah and I like how
it's over drawing with the oldest found
design noises right now
[Music]
oh he's gotta put them all down yeah
oh
oh here's the music
it's my favorite music in the game
[Music]
wow
oh my God it's the room
oh
[Music]
Recreation 101.
wow they really captured this like a
descent
[Music]
I'm a hooker
how did you get in here oh it's them I
won't let you take her
oh
my gosh
oh no
[Music]
uh the reason they focus on him yup
[__]
okay
the luck of conflict in his choice can't
keep her safe forever
no matter how hard you try
how long till she's torn apart by
infected or murdered by Raiders
she lives in a broken world that you
could have saved
so what would she decide because I think
she'd want to do what's right
do you know it
even after what you've done
we can still find a way
[Music]
I heard like how we cradled Sarah yeah
exactly gun pointed at him and
everything yeah we're running some tests
on you and some others
turns out there's a whole lot more like
you
people that are immune
dozens of them
the doctors they couldn't make any of it
work
they've actually
they've stopped looking for a cure
jeez the people hurt
yes
Marlene okay
okay
I'm taking this home
I'm sorry
damn the parallels from the first
episode of this one
you just come after her
[Music]
does not get enough credit for his music
I think the show does a better job
because of the shorter time frame too
it's easier to hone in on the parallels
between the first episode and the last
one because the game does it sure but
it's it's
it's more apparent here probably about a
five hour hike we can manage that
remember
see the conflict in Ellie well Sarah and
I used to hike like this all the time
she would have liked you
not to say you're two of you are the
same
definitely different kids well she was a
lot more
I want to say girly and I'm not saying
that you're not girly I'm not
you're also white early
do you know why I think she'd like you
why
because you're funny
anyway I bet you would have liked her
back
yeah but I wouldn't
that the rules have switched that's
great this is freaking great
how much further now it's great visual
language man
back in Kansas City you asked me about
the first time I killed someone
Riley she got bit too we didn't know
what to do and she says you can just
wait it out feel poetic and just lose
our minds together
and then she did
and I had to
she was the first to die
and then it was Tess and then Sam that's
not on you I know it look sometimes
things don't work out the way we hope
but if you just keep going
you find something new to fight for
maybe that's not what you mean
swear to me that everything you said
about the fireflies is true
I swear
okay
same music as the ending of the game
yeah dude just Goosebumps everywhere
Apple chills breaking out dude what a
freaking episode wow
yeah seriously yeah
they uh they did it the best video game
adaptation is here yeah they did it
they stuck in the landing it's
interesting Bill Ramsey said this is
going to be a very okay sorry sorry go
ahead okay I thought I thought they said
the surge's name was Darren aronovsky
just drive like really
um well obviously I was right that Abby
wasn't going to be and you said she was
so you were wrong
um but [__] all right normally I just
let this play out in real time but I
want to play it a little bit earlier so
that way Andrew gets the credit he
deserves before I continue on
I was technically right Abby was in this
episode just not that Abby we were
thinking of look at the cast right there
look at the nurses do you see a name on
there Greg Laura Bailey that is the
voice of Abby oh [__] obviously too they
they kept his face covered because
they're obviously gonna have a different
actor as well we don't know that yes I
do I know we don't know that but I found
Bella Ramsay's comment too very
interesting she said last week that this
episode is going to be very divisive for
people I don't know if she was trying to
throw off but I
I mean at least for gamers I don't see
why this episode would be divisive it
was pretty much in line with the the
exactly what happened in the game for
the most part and obviously we got a
little more expansion on uh Anna and
Marlene's relationship because the only
thing we had gotten in the video game
from that was some uh when you're
searching the hospital in the game you
find some recordings and you get to hear
a little bit about that backstory but
actually seeing it play out and of
course getting to see the great Ashley
Johnson who's got such a distinctive and
incredible voice and watching what she
had to go through and then seeing the
knife at her neck I mean that was so
freaking like tragic having a break
that's the most tragic way to have I
mean to have a baby like that and that's
insane and I just thought in the limited
amount of screen time that Ashley gave
us I imagine doing that with a clicker
attacking you on top of a bus yeah and
that would be more tragic yeah seriously
but use your imagination right no but it
was I was so glad that they were able to
get Ashley Johnson Troy Baker and uh
when we got uh uh as Perry what's his
name Jeffrey uh Pierce and that was
great to uh get all three of them in I'm
so glad Unfortunately they all got uh
epic deaths of course but yeah no I mean
it was great to get the original cast
back but this episode I I don't know
this might be my favorite episode of the
Season it was it was pretty it was
pretty close it's it's damn perfect and
notice I know you're gonna make some
jokes or nothing defending yourself
again I didn't complain about a specific
action sequence in the tunnel before you
know with infected which I freaking love
that sequence in the uh the game when
you're about to get a catch up with the
fireflies and you you know you get into
that whole water sequence I'm not
complaining that that was in here I
actually think that was smart to cut it
in this one it's not action storytelling
it's not character driven storytelling
in terms of the action don't mind that
they got rid of that there so that's why
last week for the people saying that I
was whining and playing including
yourself you know you've been texting me
like dude stop whining every episode
um but I found it I found it interesting
that uh you know you know I had to like
defend myself a little bit there it's
like there was a specific reason why
that that bothered me a little you know
it didn't hinder my love for this show I
still love the show but in this case
that's a fun action sequence in the game
but I don't I think it was a smart
choice especially for pacing purposes
that they got rid of that sequence would
have been cool visually easy of course
but I didn't mind that they got rid of
it here so sorry that I disappointed you
guys that I didn't whine in that
sequence today well Jeremy Jones said
the same thing and I actually uh
understand where you're coming from and
I think a lot of people actually said
the same thing too so yeah don't fret
man don't fret no jokes for me today I'm
going to be very serious I want jokes
not today Andrew sorry it's not my style
anymore okay I'm excited that from here
on out what people want is a serious
Greg yeah and by the way if they if
those two don't get nominated which I
think it's a it's a guarantee that they
will it's criminal if those daddy Pedro
is going to get that nomination well
both of them I think this was my
favorite episode yeah I think this was
my favorite episode for Bella or belly
by the way HBO Max thank you for what
you guys proved that you watch our
reactions because we saw on your Twitter
account that you called her belly so
thank you so much yeah yeah HBO Max give
credit where credits due it was the
first video this guy right here was the
first one to say I don't need credit I
did not find another video where they
called her belly and all right you can
have the name enjoy guys whatever HBO
Max yeah I mean um I have a couple of
things that I thought would have uh
helped enhance this episode a little bit
uh but before uh all my commentary is
overshadowed by those two little things
I will talk about for two minutes I want
to show talk about what I loved about
this first uh yeah I I thought that they
absolutely excelled like sure is it
shorter than the game yeah but you know
this is one of those things where you do
kind of have to judge it as a complete
package by the end of it all and by the
time you get to the end you know I I
think some of the best storytelling is
when you see the completion of an art
and the completion of how the beginning
of the story really mirrors the end of
the story and watching the differences
and what I really loved that they that
they really enhanced more with Joel
throughout this show but it especially
hammers it home here
is that because it is a debate in the
game of like did Joel make the right
choice people go back and forth with
that some people are there some people
don't even bother with the gray side of
the question there some people are like
he absolutely did they were gonna kill
her and the other people who are like
actually I think Joel's the villain of
the story because there was a chance
they could have had to have it have a
cure have a vaccine at least produced to
help people out right so and to me I'm
always fascinated by both sides here to
me I think about the character and I'm
like it makes sense that this character
would make this choice and what I
thought that they really really nailed
uh when it came to Joel with showing
just how destroyed he is and and all the
psychological trauma he's had to endure
that when he's going up the hill with
Ellie at the very end here and talking
about like you would have liked Sarah
and here's why
there was like as touching as it is
there was this other quality in my brain
and heart I was like there's something
else so semi-disturbing about this
because this guy is so like messed up
like so destroyed that
he will commit the the most heinous
darkest most brutal violent acts to live
in this fantasy of I have a daughter now
like she's my daughter and and look
we're gonna have this uh a life of light
from here on out and the second she
starts to try to open up about like
tests being on her uh uh like or
something that weighs on Ellie it's like
he's just no don't think about that you
know like no stop I don't you don't just
don't feel don't feel in this apartment
things are going to be good like that's
a lot of the intent about it so maybe
disturbing is too harsh of a word it's
just you could see so much of wow a lot
of these choices he made is because of
unresolved issues that this that this
guy really has and and stuff like that
carries over with into the second game
and thematically wise I think Pedro
Pascal just absolutely killed it here
because I find his version of Joel you
know like if you compare to what Troy
Baker did Troy Baker's was perhaps more
hardened and tougher uh I find what he
did here more Disturbed like this feels
like a more
like Joel in the game is in still a lot
of ways is still like kind of a fantasy
art type kind of cool guy that any guy
with emotional pain would love to be
that kind of dude like oh man I wish you
could be that cool of a guy even if I
had that mess of bull I would love to be
John Wick like who wouldn't want to be
right and here it's like this just feels
like a truly Disturbed human being like
this every every ounce of him is
the way they did the parallel of how he
had a he had his daughter in his hands
at the beginning Sarah and a gun pointed
at him
bam did Soldier shot uh at him and
killed his daughter and then here the
soldier of firefly you know Marlene she
lowers her weapon you know gives him the
choice and he makes the choice to
execute her and he commits this act of
violence in in the most cold way but
then when he's around Ellie he's all
smiles and open you know and I love it I
I think the performance is excellent and
um watching too like if you remember
that second episode when they're looking
at what's it called during their
embossing the bell tower uh oh uh the
capital the capital building yeah and
then everything you you hoped it would
be when they're looking at the you know
they have that nice moment there of
course with the giraffe which is awesome
great to see that adapted but when
they're when they're looking at Jackson
and and
in that framing we've seen in the show
how they have switched roles how Joel
has become a lot more like
and L is much more stuff yeah and then
in that moment too when they are looking
at the Capitol building in the second
episode
Ellie's the one with the hopeful look
and where their position and frame is
different and then they switch sides
here and I love the visual language of
how they have switched sides I thought
this was expertly done and you know in
in the when you're playing as Joel in
the game when he's messing up all the
Firefly soldiers of course I'm there on
Joel's side I'm not like what am I doing
I'm like you're gonna kill Ellie of
course this is ridiculous he's lying he
was saying what am I doing what am I
doing I keep moving forward and pressing
x uh that when when you're playing as
Joel there yeah and here they've made it
more of a conflict of a choice of what's
happened like they're not glorifying
this violence it's not a like go get him
Joel it's not a go mess them up and go
rescue Ellie moment at least the way
some people might still be feeling that
way but I think in the way the the
filmmakers decided to execute that it it
just felt like a descent the entire time
and how you were pointing out with like
how the music and the sound like things
were just getting drowned out and he was
just becoming cold as the violence
progressed and I loved how it if it
doesn't
it doesn't glorify the act it doesn't
glorify the violence at that moment it
could have easily just been a badass
moment with Joel in a lot of ways not
that the game does that but an
adaptation that goes wrong could have
done that but I love how they just
hammered it home like I was so impressed
with what they decided to do here uh I
have nothing but praise for this other
than one little thing and what was that
one little thing because the
the thing that makes the debate
of did Joel make the right choice or not
very strong
is the fact about when you're in the
world of the game at least
like here in the show I'm like man come
on it's pretty obvious man like say
belly but especially because the
fireflies are are just they're so cold
like even they feel colder here in this
show than they did in the game even
Marlene is like obvious like I loved the
choice that they did with I don't know I
want to give you a chance to talk about
that because I love the choice that they
did with to bring Marlene in the
beginning here to make this conflict
even harder for her so you see that
she's not just a cold-hearted [__]
about the entire thing right
um but the fire they did they did such a
good job on humanizing other camps
throughout this series but they just
make they just block this into Joel's
perspective here so you just only see
the fireflies as being so cold and the
other part is is what makes it so con uh
such a con which I like that choice but
what makes it such a conflict is the
fact that
at least in the game every moment even
when you go inside a building or
whatever you're just afraid a clicker or
an infected is around the corner or
whatever you just see how
at any moment like how necessary the
attempt for a cure is and here because
of the fact that the the infector was
kind of dialed back
I would I it made it even easier for me
to it made it even easier for me to be
swayed to the side of Joe yeah just yeah
just save Ellie there's doesn't seem
like the infected our that big of a pro
like they're a problem but they're not
they don't look like that that bad in
this world it seems like that's
something they can still
um
get under control in some way yeah
that's the thing of why I think the
complaint that some people have about a
lack of infected is it just feels like
chaos in the game and it feels there's
no way you can prevent this or stop this
or or contain it whereas here it's like
I feel like there's a way we can uh
figure out how to contain this a little
bit right yeah no I get what you're
saying you're saying a lot more in the
game it was more even though again we're
still on Joel's side there's a lot more
of a gray area then I don't know just
it's Joel Sevilla like it's it's a lot
more it's a lot more easier of a choice
here in terms of like because of the
effect it's been like you said dialed
back so much so it's a it's a lot more
Simple Choice and before I continue on
I was technically right Abby was in this
episode just not that happy we were
thinking of look at the cast right there
look at the nurses do you see a name on
there Greg Laura Bailey that is the
voice of Abby oh
[__] so uh in the comments section I'm
sure people who have not reached this
point are gonna go crazy in the comments
in front of us I noticed it after I
started after I finished I was like I'm
gonna let Greg do his whole thing and
then I'm gonna mention this I'm sure in
the comments section we're gonna hear
one of the nurses that is Abby well
clearly you didn't get to this point
because now we're mentioning it it's
hard to tell when people are wearing
masks to tell you know who who the actor
actually that's a cameo yeah no I
thought that was to put her as a cameo
in that scene too right with the doctor
oh yeah can we talk spoilers yet or no
no no spoilers okay okay uh but yes I
agree putting her in that scene yeah all
the scenes these games people will play
the second game no one yeah the people
who played like that was the perfect
scene yeah we don't need to say why yeah
I'm sure she'll get another Cameo too in
part two is or in season two rather but
uh no I mean I I hear what you're saying
and it's hard for me to argue because
the clickers were so dialed back yeah so
I I totally get where you're coming from
in regards to that
um but
yeah I mean but still again because the
the emotional conflict is is so strong
between Pedro Pascal or rather with Joel
and Ellie it again it's like he said
it's easy to get on the side of Joel but
I just thought that it's more of a wish
and I want to clarify no no of a wish
that would have enhanced the debate but
I'm not exact I'm not like bothered I
have a feeling though and again I'm sure
they knew they had a hit on their show
but I I do appreciate the fact and that
they focused more on the characters than
the action beats because if I like I
like I've always said and even in the
last episode where I had my complaining
in my whining about that one sequence
that was that was gone
if I had to make a choice between good
like nailing the characters or nailing
the action sequence it's not even close
like I want I want I want good
characters I mean yeah the action
sequences are a wish list for me but if
you can nail like the characters and
obviously know the relationship between
Joel and Ellie they like I mean you
heard Greg at the end of the reaction
this is the best video game at
adaptation of all time at least in our
subjective Minds so they nailed it from
there part of the video game adaptation
would be better like come on yeah
there's no other way I am thinking
though possibly and again I'm hoping
they continue this trend in season two
and I I've heard a lot of people saying
that Craig mazzin Mason however you say
his last name sorry if I butchered it uh
he did say that uh season two uh for
part two is going to be split up into
two seasons is what I've been hearing I
don't know if you've seen those those
comments it makes sense you can't just
in no way yeah yeah the game is forever
so
um yeah so I mean I am hope again if I
have to choose one again still keep
nailing the characters down keep doing
what you're doing I am hoping though now
that they've seen even though again they
knew they had a hit on their hands with
this show now they know they're in the
stratosphere in terms of hits yeah so
I'm hoping that we we do get more on the
infected side in terms of the action
sequences in the next season just just
to feel that Threat Level more to to pay
off in terms of what you're talking
about in terms of like you know it's not
all black and white there are some gray
areas so I I totally understand and you
are very validated in my opinion what
you're saying in regards to
I still feel the same way even in the
game I'm still rooting for Joel because
my whole thing is this I mean obviously
we've the whole in the video game
everything is from Joel and Ellie's
perspective so of course we're gonna I
mean for the most part you're gonna root
for Joel yeah obviously there's going to
be people inside well hey like what
about everyone else like they deserve to
be you know uh have the the vaccine so
that they can't get infected from the
current infected because you can't cure
the people who are already infected but
you can at least protect yourself from
being infected in the current world I
get that side of the argument even in
the video game but again we're so
invested in these characters in the
video game and you know Joel like he's
not losing another daughter that's just
that's not happening so but they do play
that interesting question of did Joel
make the right decision or not in the
game word here again because it's dialed
back it's a lot simpler of a choice is
what you're saying so no I mean I I get
what you're saying it's I I'm trying to
find a way to argue with you but because
it was dialed back so much but again I'm
still glad of the choice Joel me because
again we don't know much about the even
in the video game you don't know too
much about the fireflies I mean yeah
Marlene seems like a a good character I
mean from what we know and obviously I'm
glad they expanded upon her and Anna in
the in the beginning and also too they
what they didn't show in the video game
after she had Joel escorted out you
didn't get that moment of seeing the
pain in her eyes and seeing the tear
coming down so I thought that was a
great touch that they added here in the
show
but other than that we really don't know
much about them even in the video game
so if they did get that cure in the
vaccine
who are they going to selectively use it
are they going to be authoritarians with
how they use like we don't know exactly
how they would have used it yeah so
that's why I was more on the side of
Joel because I have no idea who these
people are what they're going to do with
it a big part of it also comes down to
that they didn't give Ellie a choice
that was the shitty part yes and I mean
they they really drive that home even
more outside yeah they drive that home
here too especially but the fact that
they robbed her of a choice is the
messed up part like everyone's deciding
for her yes and they're like don't worry
she doesn't know there's gonna be no
trauma and they they should have let her
decide and that becomes the thing that
I won't talk about
like I should really call myself yeah
um yeah they should have gave her a
choice but I think the the very uh the
introduction to to explain yeah kind of
like a blade situation as you pointed
out of like why couldn't this vampire
walk in the day yeah that's that is a
great call on what went down uh getting
Ashley Johnson back who you know I
it's really like Ellie's my favorite
video game character me too so it's not
even close so yeah like to me just like
even hearing her even though she's not
fully doing the like her voice not too
far off in the Ashley her actual Ashley
Johnson voice yeah yeah I I don't even
know if I would say it's entirely
different but like like Troy Baker's
actual voice is very is definitely doing
a jewel voice right yeah for sure
um but
you know seeing her there and then
seeing that the the kind of life that
Ellie was born into and of course
hammering home with Marlene that much
further does give you that weight of
because because it's interesting like in
the show Marlene plays his scene so much
colder when she's talking when she's
confronting Joel but in the game I don't
feel she's as that cold in the actual
game but because you got that earlier
scene you do see that that connection
yeah that she does have of like this is
everyone has to make a sacrifice here
for something bigger so I think that was
a great opening scene to have and and to
know and the way that you like catch up
with Ellie in that moment too and it
does cut to her it's like
like it felt very it felt very
purposeful to me when Marlene says cover
her ears
as if like she's just a baby like it
more like she's a baby she's not gonna
remember any of this you know so like
she's just bored but but it says cover
her ears and then bam Ellie the baby
starts to burst into tears so you do get
the sense that there is some type of
subconscious resin like memory that
lingers in the back maybe something that
Ellie doesn't obviously doesn't clearly
remember but has affected her in some
way even though it was moments after she
was born that this memory is somehow
still in her brain somewhere that has
defined her along the way yeah and the
reason also too I agree with what you
said and the reason too I also I mean
I've obviously I've praised belly all
season long but I think the reason this
episode was one of my favorites and
obviously of course they're doing from
the video game but what Bella Ramsay was
able to do in this episode just
immediately when we see her just showing
how traumatized she is by what David by
what she had gone through with David and
how I mentioned it in the last episode
like a part of her soul and so much rage
has been pent up into Ellie which we
might possibly see you later don't want
to get in spoilers but again just just
seeing how traumatized she is because
you gotta remember I mean yes it's been
dialed back
she is lives in a world where she is
hunted by clickers infected and hunters
and Raiders and all this stuff I mean
she sees some messed up stuff but it
took a preacher dude that wanted to make
her her pet and and was a pedophile that
really struck a chord with her and like
traumatized her like beyond belief and I
just saw it Bella Ramsay like and you
can look at these words on a page and
say yeah traumatized the way she was
able to emote and and express that
through her body language through her
facial expressions
I really I mean again just my subjective
opinion she was fantastic all season I
loved every episode she was in she just
got better every episode yeah but she
really stood like above The Fray in this
I mean Pedro Pascal was so freaking good
in this episode too but she was on
another level for me in this episode
like she rose up to the to Kingdom come
in this episode she was so freaking good
like I just I felt every second like of
how traumatized she was just it from the
beginning to just when she couldn't hear
jokes like what it just again I know
it's from the game but again it's it's
what Bella Ramsey was able to do in her
performance in this episode body
language facial expression wise just
really impressive I'm just so impressed
well there's a lot of things about that
giraffe scene that I've heard people I
mean I haven't really heard anyone talk
about it but I can I could fathom that
there's a lot of ways to sort of
interpret that moment and to me you know
there's such a loss of Innocence that
has occurred with Ellie
uh based off the events of like what we
saw with David and such and who she's
turned into that you know you see this
childlike innocence come back by looking
at something that just seems so
pure like they're just giraffes being
how giraffes are in this really messed
up world they're not looking around the
the environments going like what
happened to our city and the economy and
the world and to be like they're just
being giraffes so they're they're still
there's a there's still a family of
giraffes they're gonna live on like
there's there's such a purity to it and
then it brings out this childlike Wonder
within Ellie like there is an innocence
that is regained in that moment and
that's what's heartbreaking about it at
the same time when you're seeing how
they smile because there's so much hurt
underneath that smile at the same time
you know yeah no definitely I also had
two a weird visual parallel too like
when you know when the infected when the
runners or the stalkers when they you
know when the quarter steps come out of
their mouth and they're trying to infect
you obviously you have to stay away from
it but when the giraffe was sticking its
tongue out and she was able to actually
touch it it was like I I was getting
some visual callback like no this is an
innocent animal that you can pet it you
can you and let it lick you with its
tongue so I thought that was really
interesting that they really focused on
that because I don't remember them the
video game where you actually saw the
giraffe's tongue come out like that I
don't remember the thing in the game
about Joel I'm trying to unlive himself
yeah that I don't remember any of that
at all I remember that scene and then I
don't remember that conversation
happening and I think that that is a v
that to me
is a necessary addition absolutely like
that is so there's some there's like
qualities you know like nice addition
um better Edition and then there's
necessary Edition because to me I have
always wondered that like
how did this guy just not try to attempt
this at one point because come on like
after everything you've been through it
all you're moping around of course this
guy would at some point right would have
had to have attempted that so I thought
like then having a whole detail to that
story like something that they did set
up one I want to say that third episode
um when she's talking about the scar in
his head and then two explain that yeah
but there was something that
that made him Flinch that made him go I
guess I guess I just have to survive and
endure endure and survive right and then
he's telling the story to Ellie and it's
like this is my purpose you yeah this is
why I'm still here I thought it was I
thought acknowledging that all that was
so to me I'm like thank you for saying
that because this is a conversation I've
been like having with myself like how
did Joel never attempt this and in the
game and we can talk about this because
it's from the first game it's not from
the second game in that moment in the
video game
Ellie gives Ellie gives Joel a picture
that the whole scene was emitted in you
know so when Joel goes to visit Tommy at
the the power plant uh that we didn't
get to see in the show but in the game
he shows him the picture because he went
back to Texas back to their house and
they showed him a picture of Joel and
Sarah together where she was playing
soccer and they've just had a happy
moment it was like right before outbreak
and we see that Tommy is trying to give
Joel that picture and he doesn't want it
and then we see that Ellie snat we
didn't see Ellie snatch it but in the
background she did snatch it and then in
that moment in the game she gives it to
uh to Joel to just make him feel better
in the moment but I thought they were
going to go that route but I I and I
still would have loved that but I really
like this too it was so freaking well
done like it was just executed so
perfectly it was such a beautiful
addition and then again just like you
said the the whole line of like I I did
feel that way and basically in subtext
still I met you and I just thought the
line was so beautifully delivered and
again the way
belly just reacted to it was just like
chef's kiss so perfect I mean they're
just so good together those two like you
guys can understand too it's more than
just actors for the game who do The
Voice work like they're they're mokey
like we keep saying that but it is they
are mocaps so it is they are doing the
whole performance yeah and those are our
iconic performances they are they are
literally iconic
so for them to step into this different
medium of live action and then to make
it their own where I just stop comparing
the way delivery is done yeah I just
like I don't even think about it
sometimes I'm like oh they remember that
line from the game but I'm so invested
in what they're doing is very impressive
you know it's a challenge that a lot of
play actors often have and to see that
they've done it here is incredible I
thought they were excellent I think they
both desert reminisce another thing I
don't think it's talked about in night
because it's not as we point out like
something here or there I think the way
this show is shot is great like it just
looks beautiful it's a beautiful looking
show that doesn't depending on the
episode sometimes they do decide to go
like let's make this look like [__]
popping you know but more often than not
they just make they while there's like a
lot of cool visual flourishes they still
never lose sight of we want this to feel
real at the same time uh I think they
did an excellent job there everything on
the technical department and yeah sure
once in a while you could see like let's
go earlier greens go like the same with
the Giraffe you're like the green screen
what's going on here
um but more often than not I don't even
notice it more often than that like I
only notice it really when I'm like okay
I could see like a little thing here or
there that guy can tell like or
sometimes your subconscious eye can just
see it but most of the time like the way
they've brought a lot of the destruction
the overgrown weeds and the grass and
then the rubble uh all that is excellent
and the fact that they've chosen
specific key sequences uh for their sets
to completely resemble like the hospital
like we're gonna link this look exactly
like how it was in the game and but
we're not just gonna show it off we want
there to really be a specific mood and
emotion like everything every choice
even if it aesthetically harkened back
to the game seemed like they would put
it in there if there was an emotional
purpose to serve it and I think that's
the best way you can do this adaptation
they did it look at all these looks like
Indian people who worked on this uh as a
digital artist for this show
um they were amazing yeah this is a this
is this was uh this is an incredible
experience and I'm so happy with it uh
they like a lot of times
you think you see this with a lot of
Marvel shows too where you're like this
is good but they man they dropped the
like they're the Lasting Impression me
can mean so much that can mean we can
sometimes outweigh the entire experience
leading up to it
but but if you nail that finale like
poof man like they they did it and none
of these episodes to do and uh I could
have gone for longer uh I I can't wait
for season two the non-controversy
season I can't always wait for that [__]
you guys have if you haven't played if
you don't know what happens in that game
you are not ready for the kind of [__]
is coming your way yeah because if if
this faithfulness is anything of a
testament to like wow we want to honor
the game
um I I'm like it's gonna be a very
different Journey because it's season
two and again without getting into
spoilers they have foreshadowed and set
the seeds in place that yeah for people
who have played the game of part two we
know what's coming I mean obviously I'm
sure they're going to take Liberties
like they did in this one with expanding
certain moments cutting out certain
things and doing that kind of stuff but
they even enhanced like they gave us an
extra shot in that hospital thing that
we like oh God I don't want to point it
out yes I know what you're talking about
that but like they lingered on a
specific dead body for a reason yep and
I was like man they're they are setting
it up lingered on that [__] linger is
the key word so
um guys what did you think about the
finale have you already bought a last of
a shirt that's the most important thing
um follow Andrew igor711 on Instagram
and Twitter uh right now he's getting so
many followers mainly from the jabby COA
side of things and I hate that I loathe
it with a passion a fury in me so can
you guys please go follow him from the
real rejects Camp I hate it I hate it so
much I hate you I hate him I hate most
people I kind of like my wife she's okay
she's she's great she gets a pass I love
her unconditionally do I like her though
you know because she's my job uh and uh
follow us on patreon and
um let's do a patreon
Michael B Michael B right now I know you
are slaving away as well it's chopping
editing to get your last of us reaction
up here on the channel Omni media him
and I just did a reaction together for
the movie called knock at the cabin uh
he's one of my favorite people I love
talking with this guy uh he's a true
Talent a real Gem and uh if you guys
like reaction videos if you like
reactors but great commentary Michael B
omnimedia he is the channel to go to way
better than this term I suck I'm a
whiner or anything he's at the jabby COA
side of things
that's where that's where the recycling
bin goes
all all you people or what's it called
now I don't even know the name of it
oh my God
you know you're desperately you gotta
change your name like that
come on defend your new family you're
gonna say you're desperate sex when you
gotta find me on the the channel but
no
you were here first I don't have friends
I got family you were here first Andrew
yeah all I know is buried me
I did I did I did I love you I love you
both of you guys I'm not picking aside
so I'll let you I'll let you two do you
mean if there was a side you wouldn't
pick the one you met the one who brought
you to YouTube I'll save that comment
for off camera
I'm gonna bring that man in this room
and we're gonna have this private
conversation on camera we're gonna be
like come here boy come here come here
oh yeah Michael B go follow him